et dit : « Pourquoi ne pas louer un van,
pour aller dans les cinq arrondissements de New York
voir combien nous en visitons en une fois.
Il y avait 60 bibliothèques.
Donc, nous en avons probablement visité une demi-douzaine dans une longue journée.
Le plus beau, ce fut de rencontrer les bibliothécaires qui les dirigeaient,
avaient pris possession de ces lieux comme leur scène privée
sur laquelle ils étaient invités à fasciner leurs étudiants
et faire revivre les livres.
Ce fut une expérience vraiment passionnante pour nous tous
de voir ces choses en action.
Nous passâmes une longue journée à faire ça.
Nous étions dans la dernière bibliothèque.
C'était encore l'hiver, car il fit sombre tôt.
La bibliothécaire dit : « Je vais fermer. C'est un plaisir de vous avoir ici.
Une minute. Voulez-vous voir comment j'éteins les lumières ? »
Moi : « D'accord ! »
Elle dit : « J'ai une manière spéciale. » Et elle me montra.
Ce qu'elle faisait, c'est couper chaque lumière une à une...
et la dernière qu'elle laissait allumée,
était la lumière qui éclairait le visage des enfants,
Elle dit : « C'est la dernière lumière que j'éteins chaque nuit,
car j'aime me rappeler pourquoi je viens travailler. »
Donc !
Quand j'ai commencé, souvenez-vous, il s'agissait juste d'un logo
d'intelligence et d'un nouveau nom ?
La conséquence involontaire ici, dont j'aimerais bien m'attribuer le crédit
et penser que je peux songer à une expérience de cette ampleur,
mais je ne peux pas.
J'étais juste concentré sur les 30 cm devant moi,
à portée de ma main.
À l'opposé, très loin là-bas, il y avait une bibliothécaire
qui allait découvrir la chaîne de conséquences
que nous avions mis en marche, une source d'inspiration
qui lui permettrait, dans ce cas, de faire un excellent travail.
40 000 enfants par an sont touchés par ces bibliothèques.
Elles sont là depuis plus de dix ans maintenant.
Ces bibliothécaires ont poussé une génération d'enfants vers les livres.
Ce fut une joie de découvrir
que les conséquences involontaires sont parfois les meilleures conséquences.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)